let's bring in louisiana senator john
kennedy recently joined the gop
delegation
on tour of border facility in donna
texas good morning to you senator
good morning good morning if you look at
these numbers deportations
they are an arrest of illegal immigrants
in the u.s have fallen
sharply under biden's watch if you look
at the numbers let's take
last december that was the last full
month under president trump
there were 5735 ice deportations
now look at february that full month
that was the first full month under
biden
2590. but just less people coming here
that's all
right right there are more people coming
and fewer arrests what do you think
about that
why is that and what what's your
reaction
sometimes when people act like they
don't care
it's not an act i think
president biden just doesn't care
i think he uh he plans
on admitting between two and three
million illegal immigrants
into our country this year uh we had
hints of that
in his campaign future dreamers uh
true but but also just letting people
in illegally at the border this is
dangerous
uh the border patrol told me that at
least people from 55 countries
have already come in wow people from all
over the world
are going giving to mexico and flooding
in number two
it's a very expensive many of
these folks will go on welfare uh
particularly if they can make it to a
sanctuary city or a blue state
it puts downward pressure on wages
and it unreservedly undermines legal
immigration
which most americans support now
in further evidence of what i i just
suggested
the president has put vice president
harris in charge of trying to combat the
illegal immigration
there's some confusion she says she
doesn't want it
the president says she's got to take it
but no disrespect to
the vice president i know her well i
respect her but
but she believes in open borders making
her the
illegal immigration czar as i said the
other day
he's like making el chapo the drug czar
right and by the way they are sending a
special envoy to the northern
triangle areas of guatemala and el
salvador between april 5th and 8th take
your time
and kate tobin the senior director for
trans border security uh will be one
there as well as
another guy named envoy zanuga so
they're going
why is it taking two months and why
isn't the vice president going evidently
she was working the phones over the
weekend
is that enough well if all they do is
take
billions and billions of american
taxpayer money
and give it to the governments of the
northern triangle
countries um they might as well throw it
in the dirt
that money's going to be stolen it'll
never make it to the people
now if what the envoy is going to do is
talk to the governments in the northern
triangle countries
and say look we can do this the easy way
or the hard way
uh we're we're going to set up um uh
processing centers in your country and
allow people to apply for refugee status
in your country and adjudicate the
claims there they're not coming into the
united states
and if you don't do that then we're
going to make you an offer you can't
refuse
that's what trump did but i don't think
that's what they're going to do i think
they're just going to take
uh billions of taxpayer money and give
it to the
authoritarian governments which are
going to promptly steal it
oh man you know the biggest thing on
your agenda for right now
in the senate and the congress as well
senator is the fact that it looks like
this gigantic two trillion dollar
infrastructure bill
is heading your way the big question is
will any republicans be on board
the uh the two trillion dollar train
probably not but pete bootage edge the
secretary of transportation listen to
this senator
he says the boss wants this done fast
know that this is entering a legislative
process where we're going to be hearing
from both sides of the aisle and i think
you'll find the president's got a very
open mind but
time is of the essence so we'll look at
these ideas on how to pay for it we'll
look at ideas
on where the investments ought to be too
but the president is hoping for
major progress from congress before
memorial day
and we can't allow this thing to to just
keep dragging on because the need is
there today
and speaking of today senator uh today
in the new york post on the op-ed page
they talk about how the single biggest
line item
of of money in that particular
infrastructure build
not for bridges or tunnels but it's for
millions of healthcare jobs because
there's strings attached to it the white
house
memo of understanding says the money
will be tied to healthcare workers
getting the ability
to collectively bargain in other words
you want the money
you're going to have to join a union
well let's let's leave long island land
for a while this is not an
infrastructure bill
um if you think this is an
infrastructure bill you probably better
stay away from sharp objects
this is a this is a green new deal
yep welfare and reparations bill
being charitable less than 10 of the
bill
is devoted to infrastructure and we
don't even know what the projects are
you know who picked some projects
speaker pelosi senator schumer and
president biden
now one need not be clairvoyant to see
that their projects are going to end up
in new york and california and blue
states
so there you have it you've got a
political slush fund
and you you can you can say
that and maybe even believe that two
plus two equals five
but just because you say it doesn't make
it true the correct answer is four
this is not an infrastructure bill it's
also outrageously expensive
uh there is no free lunch and you don't
get one now they're gonna pay for
for it through more debt and uh higher
taxes
let's talk about what's happening now
will they work with us i hope so i hope
they do i'll
they say they do old man backflips if
they'll work with us but
but i don't i don't have i don't have my
hopes up they say that they will we'll
see
um mlb moving the all-star game out of
atlanta
because they changed the election laws
there it's going to cost that area about
10 million dollars according to the
tourism industry
i'm sorry 100 million and um
this is cecilia rousey listen to this
this she's talking about the economic
impact
she's a biden advisor
it's a little early to judge what the
economic impact will be
but they have a right to to vote with
their feet and to
and to express their dissatisfaction
with the laws there is undoubtedly going
to be a cause i think that was the point
that the major league baseball was
trying to make major league baseball
will however move
its its game and workers at another
place will benefit
you know that is exactly the message
that major league baseball was trying to
send
these companies have the opportunity to
vote with their feet
and they're using their economic power
to just express their dissatisfaction
the reason they're doing that is joe
biden is out there
spreading misinformation some people are
calling him a liar listen to chris
christie
joe biden's broken his own rule eight
and now he's lying to the american
people george
he's lying about this bill he's lying to
the american people about it to cause
the raging fire
he said he was going to put out i'm very
disappointed what's so wrong with having
to show a voter id
to vote in person what's wrong with and
and to vote
if you're mailing in your ballot and
what's wrong with having
yeah signature verification isn't that
fair
i think it is number one i think
president biden has done the country of
great disservice by by not telling the
truth about this bill
uh i mean he either he's lying or he's
lost
uh number two the commissioner of
baseball is mr ron
manfred um
he's just made baseball a blue sport
he did i don't get it i don't get it i
mean
his attendances is declining if if
if it were my job i would try to be
adding
fans the only thing i can figure is that
mr manfred is part
of the what i call the managerial elite
the entrenched politicians the
bureaucrats
the the certain members of the media the
academics the corporate phonies
who think they're smarter and more
virtuous than the people they make money
off of and
as best i can tell mr manfred just wet
his
pants and delight at the chance
to virtue signal here and all he did was
make
major league baseball a blue sport i i
don't get it
right and watch them move it to new york
where they're destroying it's even more
restricted
than george's changes it's unbelievable
he didn't read the bill it's lazy
and it's cowardly uh for them to do that
but here's the other here's the other
one go ahead sure
i was just gonna say uh what what my
democratic friends want they want two
things
they want no id and they want to be able
to ballot harvest
well tough
you know that that's going to undermine
the integrity
or the perception of the integrity of
every single election we will go through
every time what we went through last
time
and it's it's just foolish i don't
unders
and if you don't agree that you
shouldn't have to
that you should have to present an id
you're a racist
and by the way is it a rate are you go
ahead
i'm just saying to compare it to jim
crow
a democratic initiative from the 1880s
is so outlandish jim crow on steroids
jim crow had a poll tax a literacy tax
it was a way to keep african americans
from voting or minorities from voting
period
this has nothing to do with that and we
it brings out
water go ahead
i was just going to say my guess is when
you go to
pick up your your season
tickets for major league baseball if
anybody's still buying them
at least on my side of the aisle my
guess is you have to show an i.d
yep you do a final topic for you
senator for months before the election
the mainstream media would not touch the
hunter biden story and just in the month
before the election
there's that story about the laptop
showing up at the shop
in delaware new york post broke the
story
fox news broke the story as well
hunter biden was asked about it by cbs
over the last couple of days after
everybody on his side said you know what
that's just russian disinformation not
true
now as it turns out hunter says yeah
could be mine
listen was that your laptop
for real i don't know i know but you
know that's this i really don't know
okay the answer is
you don't know yes or no off the laptop
i don't have the idea
i've no idea what could have been yours
of course certainly it
there could be a laptop out there that
was stolen from me that could be that i
was hacked it could be that it was
that it was russian intelligence it
could be that it was stolen from me
so senator now he says it certainly
could be my laptop but before the
election it was
nope it certainly was russian
disinformation
well i i don't know mr hunter biden i do
know
that his father allowed mr hunter biden
to send the message to the world that
american foreign policy can be
bought like a sack of potatoes and
that's wrong
number two i don't know why he has
released this book
right now one point of view
is that he's trying to send a message
that he is not responsible for anything
that he does
because he's an addict
um and that's an interesting point of
view
i do believe addiction is a crippling
disease
but i also believe in
free will and personal responsibility
and and i don't think
you can be absolved of everything you
don't
do wrong in this world no matter
whether you're an addict or not or how
you're feeling or what somebody did to
you
because you say it's not my fault i
can't help it
i don't think that's a defense in a
court of law does this help his dad
uh i don't see how but i think it
probably helps him i mean the impression
that i kind of get from
i haven't read the book i'm gonna be
fair but i've read excerpts and i've
read
seen the news reports and i think the
message that he's trying to send
is i'm not responsible for anything that
i do
because uh be because i like uh
christ cocaine and heroin yeah and and
that's
uh that's a pretty honest
view of the world in my judgment it
certainly has nothing to do with
personal responsibility but again he's
trying to make a profit off it isn't it
yes i'm i'm you know
he's he's gonna make a lot of money well
let's see
if any of that stuff turns out to be bad
for him
a book comes out i think tomorrow
senator thanks for coming out today
thank you folks thank you